الى السوق الحره نروح نشتري يلا ما بين
التوفير والتبذير في رحله المسافر في فقره
اقتصادك نصائح من الخبراء حول المتاجر
المعفيه من الضرائب ماذا اشتري
خلينا نشوف لانه مناطق المغادره في معظم
المطارات الدوليه الكبرى اصبحت محطات تسوق
ضخمه لبضائع معفى من الضرائب لا يسهل
مقاومتها الهيئه وانا واحده منهم عند
السفر على الرغم من ان مبدا السوق الحره
هو البيع من دون ضرائب
الا ان هذا لا يعني ان كافه المنتجات فيها
ارخص هناك بعض السلع فيها اغلى او يكون
مبالغه ايضا في سعرها يجب ابدا عدم شراء
عمل المطر كونها اغلب التاكيد بالفعل
فماذا مشاهدينا نشتري من السوق الحره ومتى
وما لا تعرفه عن هذه الاسواق طبعا مع
زميلتنا سمر المشطه في فقره اقتصادك
[موسيقى]
اللهم لينا هنا في الاستديو ولا على هذا
الكرسي المختلف عن هذاك سمر الماشطه
طيب سمر خليني اسالك وين سوق الحره الكلام
كثير لكن دفع الرسوم على السلع
المعفاه من الجمرك المفترض انها تكون ارخص
هي ارخص نشتري في الحره حسب السوق الحره
هناك بعض الاسواق الحره تلاقيها اغلى
وهناك بعض الاسواق الحرت تلاقيها ارخص
المهم الان نصائح الخبراء تقول انه قبل اي
ما تشتري اي سرعه مو بس في السوق الحره في
اي مكان في العالم تشيك اونلاين اليوم ويا
عده مواقع اون لاين الاون لاين صاروا
هوايه ارخص سواء من المحادثه التجاريه او
حتى من السوق الحره في بعض الاحيان فاذا
عندك شيء معين تريدين تشتريه تشك على
الاون لاين قبل ما تذهبين الى السوق الحره
وخصوصا
العطور مثلا
العطور ممكن تلاقيها اليوم في باركنز ارخص
الميك اب ما في فرق كبير بين السوق الحره
يعني صار الفرق جدا بسيط
سمر في عنا نقاط احنا راح نذكرها خلينا
نشرح عنهم اول شيء اول نقطه مهمه على ما
يبدو الخبراء بيقولوا لنا انه ننتبه عليها
لازم الاحتفاظ بفواتير الشراء من السوق
الحر ليش خلاص مش راح نرجع لهالبلد احيانا
بعض
بعض المعاملات ما تقدرين تخلصيها بالسوق
الحره يعني انا صارت معي لما رجعت من
ايطاليا ما كان عندي وقت اخلص الامور في
السوق الحره اللي كنت طالعه منها فلما
رجعت الى دبي سويت يعني عبيت الفايلز
وعبيت
الابليكيشن ورجعت بعدتها ورجعوا بعتولي
الفلوس فاحيانا ممكن ترجع تطالب بها بعد
ما ترجع الى بلدك مو بالسوق الحره نفسها
اذا كنت متاخر على الطياره في السوق الحره
بعضها انا من اشوف كلمه هذه المنتج خاص
بهذه السوق الحره اروح اشتري العطر على
طول لكن يمكن يكون اغلى اغلى من بره
الاكسكلوسه بعاده تكون اغلى بس بالمجمل
العطور هي من الاشياء المفضله شرائها في
السوق الحره تكون عاده ارخص وتكون ايضا
يمكن نسبه فيها شويه اعلى فيبقى العطر
اكثر مما لو تشتريها من البلدان خصوصا
البلدان الاسلاميه طبعا فممكن يبقى العطر
اكثر من
ترك حلوه يعني طيب في سوق حره عند بمبنى
المغادرين وفي بمبنى القادمين صحيح انو
افضل نشتري لانه يعني الخبراء بقولوا
افضلك افضلك يعادل عند المغادره دايما عند
المغادره هي مبينه هي اكبر وعندك خيارات
اكثر دائما لما ترجعين سوق القادمين يكون
جدا صغير وما في خيارات فدائما المغادره
افضل بس احب انوه انه صار يعني سوق الحره
نفسه مثل مول صارت الناس تروح ابكر لتتسوق
من هناك العام صارت المبيعات وصلت 38
مليار دولار في اسواق الحره عالميا هذا
الرقم حيتذبل الى 70 مليار دولار خلال
السنتين القادمه فصار يعني سوق الحره نفسه
ممكن نسميه مثل مول كبير للتسوق
حسب
هذه الاشياء اللي تلاقينها
اروح قبل اربع ساعات يعني مثلا شانيل عندك
انك رايحه عالمول يعني شانيل 12% ارخص في
دبي ديوتي فري من المولات نفسها يعني
الصراحه صورتها اعتمد على قرارات شراء
مثلا ديور لا نفس السعر
اكثر من السوق الحره ولا لا ممكن اكثر بس
اذا انت تريد شيء بيسك وتعرف حيكون موجود
وتشيء
معينه لازم تساوي قبل ما تروح شكرا جزيلا
لك سمر على كل هذه المعلومات شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات